Abbiamo dimenticato di nuovo i
ragazzi rubiamo tutti i regali di
[Musica]
[Applauso]
compleanno che
schifo proverò a parlarci a mandarla
via
[Applauso]
[Musica]
Eccolo il mio preferito non è vero Anita
l'ha comprato per me no l'ha comprato a
tutti e due non è vero Sì è vero è
sempre stato il mio preferito fin da
piccolo anche il mio quindi perché lo
devi avere per forza tu vai a giocare
con le tue Barbie brutte non ne ho
voglia di giocare con le Barbie ho
voglia di giocare con questo l'ho preso
prima io Ah sono sempre i soliti io
mentre gioco con il mio cappello cacca
Oh ma come ti sta bene quel cappello e a
me come mi sta questo
Wow tieni tu Basta Mi sono stancato
giochiamo un po' ai videogiochi Va bene
a che cosa giochiamo
B Tanti auguri a Luna Tanti auguri a
Luna Tanti
auguri
allora Tanti auguri a
te Oggi è il compleanno della piccola
Luna Sì esatto è per il suo compleanno
oggi dobbiamo partire e dobbiamo anche
sbrigarci perché l'aereo sta per partire
siete tutti pronti Voi siete pronti Sì
no aspetta ancora 5 minuti Abbiamo
appena
iniziato ragazzi Dobbiamo partire
Allora questi sono sequestrati
sequestrati li riavrete Quando saremo
Partiti Ma è un'eternità ma non fa
niente Ci giocherete dopo tranquilli Sì
ma adesso come facciamo ci annoiamo ma
l'aereo sta partendo dobbiamo andare
subito non possiamo rischiare come
l'altra volta di dimenticarci di voi Qua
a casa come nell'episodio precedente se
non l'avete visto andate a vederlo dopo
questo video presto partiamo subito
seguiteci subito in macchina Ok Andi
andiamo presto Ragazzi Fuori fuori
dobbiamo partire andiamo andiamo dai
ragazzi via si parte la valigia La
valigia l'ho preso Oh sì
Ah finalmente ci siamo questa volta ci
siamo tutti non c'è il rischio che ci
dimentichiamo nessuno perché siamo tutti
in macchina quindi siamo tutti pronti
per partire
Sì sì
Pronti Via non ci dovevi essere perché
sei seduta vicino a me mettetela Perché
litigate sempre perché è un
carciofo non è
veroo non è
vero Ok tutti pronti allacciamo le
cinture di sicurezza e si
parte Ok cinture ci sono pronti ragazzi
Sì si parte oh oh no aspetta Ho
dimenticato una cosa importantissima
devo assolutamente prenderla eh Arrivo
subito devi andare a prendere qualcosa
che cosa Eh un cioccolatino devo
prendere un cioccolatino per il viaggio
ma ritorno subito faccio davvero in
frettissima davvero ci impiego un attimo
un cioccolatino Uffa Vitale Sei sempre
il solito Pensi sempre a mangiare Io nel
frattempo vado di nuovo a salutare
Merlino e i nostri amici pelosetti che
mi mancheranno tantissimo voi Mi
raccomando non Muovetevi dalla macchina
rimanete in macchina perché l'aereo sta
per partire torniamo subito Sì certo
Anita stiamo in macchina Sì
sì
oh quale
prendo ma io li prendo tutti Sì sì li
prendo tutti così mi serviranno per il
viaggio in macchina per il viaggio in
aereo per la pausa durante l'aereo per
quando per quando sarò solo e affamato
li prendo tutti mi assaggio uno Adesso
però via è tardi Devo
[Musica]
andare Dov'è Merlino devo salutarlo Ehi
mi sono dimenticata di dirvi una cosa
tantissima e cioè che oggi saluto
Floriana che ha scritto questo
bellissimo messaggio Ciao Anita sei
fantastica Il mio il mio momento
preferito è stato quando le bambine
hanno fatto la ceretta Vitale era
divertentissimo sono una tua fan e mi
chiamo Floriana e ti prometto che
prenderò il libro La città stregata
Grazie mille Floriana se non avete visto
il video di cui sta parlando andate a
vederlo dopo questo video e se anche voi
volete essere salutati cliccate subito
mi piace sotto a questo video guardate
il video fino alla fine fine scrivete
nei commenti Qual è stato il vostro
momento preferito ma Ora sbrighiamoci
l'aerea sta per partire Ecco Merlino
Ciao Merlino Stiamo partendo anche se ti
ho già salutato Volevo salutarti di
nuovo Non ti preoccupare adesso arriverà
la dog sitter Mi mancherai tantissimo in
questo
viaggio mi raccomando Fai da bravo con
la dogsitter Noi torniamo presto ma
adesso dobbiamo partire mi mancherai
tantissimo Ciao amore mio a presto Uffa
per però questo viaggio sarà noiosissimo
senza qualcosa con cui giocare Hai
proprio
ragione perché non prendiamo i miei
videogiochi sono tutti bellissimi
andiamo andiamo andiamo ma non possiamo
andare Anita e Vitale Ci hanno detto di
restare in macchina Sì ma saremo
velocissimi ci metteremo un attimo va
bene andiamo Però facciamo presto sì
prima che torni Anita evitare senò ci
sgridano andiamo andiamo Sì saremo
velocissimi Andiamo andiamo
[Musica]
Oh no vit dobbiamo fare in fretta ok
Eccoli Eccoli ragazzi piano non possiamo
prenderli tutti usiamo questa io prendo
Just questo è bello Cav Ok Super Mario
no Just Dance No scegliete un gioco e
basta Muovetevi però che l'aereo sta per
partire dobbiamo partire anche noi dai
io C compleanno posso sceglierlo io il
videogioco E va bene per oggi lo scegli
tu però solo per oggio Esatto Ora però
sbrighiamoci perché siamo in
ritardissimo corri anite e vitale
Saranno già giù correte es
Andiamo correta ragazzi
corret Dov'è la
macchina ma dov'è la macchina Oh no mi
sei successo di nuovo Sono partiti senza
di no
adesso come
facciamo lo sapevo che avremmo avuto
l'occasione di rubare in questa casa di
nuovo cara la mia collega e questa volta
riuscirò anche ad andare in bagno ma
perché non ti metti un pannolino adesso
dobbiamo concentrarci sul fatto che
dobbiamo entrare in quella casa e
prendere tutti i gioielli Ma quali
gioielli io non posso indossare i
gioielli le collane gli orecchini a me
non me ne frega niente di queste cose a
me interessano i giochi i pupazzi i LEGO
le Barbie Oh quanto amo le Barbie hai
detto le Barbie Sì le Barbie ha detto le
Barbie ti mando via calci nel sedere Se
non la
smetti concentrati dobbiamo entrare in
quella casa Hai capito Va bene Mi fa
male la testa adesso ti concentri Sì sì
e ci prepariamo un piano perché dobbiamo
entrare dentro la casa per rubare senza
essere scoperti Esatto E poi anche per
andare in bagno ti ho detto che ti devi
prendere un pannolino smettila dai
sbrighiamoci me la sto facendo
sotto Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita è
uscito il mio nuovo libro La città
stregata con un nuovissimo miso da
risolvere insieme a Vitale in più dentro
c'è l'alfabeto segreto con cui comunichi
tanti messaggi segreti assieme per i
primi ordini Riceverete anche il poster
autografato quindi prendetelo subito
trovate il link in descrizione Oppure lo
trovate in
libreria anche questa volta siamo
riusciti a prendere l'aereo per un pelo
stava per partire senza di noi e io ho
fatto anche in tempo a prendere tutti i
miei Snap preferiti Che buoni Ah a
proposito Quasi dimenticavo ragazzi Vi
devo dare i
cellulari
ragazzi
Ragazzi abbiamo dimenticato di nuovo i
ragazzi siamo rimasti a casa da soli di
nuovo e ora come facciamo a me non
interessa così posso giocare molto più
tempo con i videogiochi Sì
Evviva è troppo bello È troppo
divertente stere son Dio tutto il
giorno Che bello stare da soli a casa
senza genitori senza nessun problema
Sì in effetti avete proprio ragione
perché non andiamo di nuovo a mangiare
tutti i cioccolatini erano così buoni
l'ultima volta no Aspetta però non
facciamo come l'altra volta che abbiamo
mangiato tutti i dolci così non ci
resterà più nulla Sì infatti ne mangiamo
un po' adesso e un po' a cena così
adesso abbiamo più tempo per giocare e
Allora giochiamo
[Applauso]
pri
questo pri No
mio è
bellissimo in
faccia è
[Musica]
preferito
questo
sì Ho dimenticato il mio cappello nella
cameretta luna mi accompagni certo
adesso ti accompagno vieni
[Musica]
andiamo Ma sei
impazzito asetta
questa volta è stato proprio facile
entrare in casa quei marmocchi non si
sono accorti di niente Beh per me non
era molto Fac
ti è uscito il bernoccolo
guarda un altro
scappellotto adesso iniziamo a cercare
qualcosa Vediamo che cosa abbiamo qui
Ehi
guarda ora sembriamo fratello e sorella
Guarda voglio togliere la cuffia non
voglio essere sorella di uno che se la
sta sempre per fare addosso E vabbè ma
non è colpa mia se non trovo un
gabinetto sempre nelle vicinanze Eh
aspetta aspetta che c'è Che c'è ma i
miei occhi vedono
[Musica]
bene gioielli gioielli giell una corona
una corona una corona mi sento una vera
regina aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta
Eccolo
qua un anello È
bellissimo Se solo ci fosse qualcuno che
che me lo metta al dito Vabbè Me lo
metterò da sola Guardate come mi sta
bene un bracciale Che
bello sono in paradiso sto davvero per
svenire i gioielli ma io a me non mi
servono i gioch
Oh ma questi
sono io adoro i giochi che belli io
adoro i giochi Guarda questo Bell No
guarda questo anche questo Questo è
bellissimo Oh no è fantastico
questo Aspetta un secondo ma quello
Oh ma questi sembrano regali di
compleanno Oh che bello oh che bello qua
il più fortunato Sono io che li ho
trovati Oh ma questo è
grandissimo buon compleanno Luna Oh Luna
quanto mi dispiace ma io ora ti Ruberò
tutti i regali Ehi Ginny Vieni vieni
Guarda Guarda cosa ho trovato Sì no
vabbè i regali Fammi vedere questo Oh
guarda che forma ha questo potrebbe
essere la bacchetta di Harry Potter no
macare ma te l'ho sempre voluta anche io
non me l'hanno mai
comprata ma forse adesso ce l'avremo
Finalmente adesso che abbiamo la
bacchetta di Harry Potter possiamo
finalmente rubare tutto dalle altre case
con facilità Oh ma che bello oh
diventeremo i ladri più bravi del mondo
andiamo riamo tutti i regali di
[Musica]
compleanno e Voi chi siete e chi siamo
noi
siamo
Siamo qui per il compleanno di Luna
abbiamo portato i regali ce l'ai il
regali Sì c'abbiamo i regali non vi
credo voi Siete dei ladri No guarda in
realtà non siamo dei ladri vorremmo
andare in bagno perché a lui scappa
sempre non è che ci potete dire dov'è
Non vi crediamo Voi siete dei lagri e
siete qui per
[Musica]
rubare
Che
[Musica]
schifo questo è lo scorreggio più lungo
che abbia sentito nella mia vita ma non
è che oltre lo schar regggio hai fatto
anche qualcos'altro oh no
che Che schifo
scappiamo
dormiglione Oh No sono di nuovo tornati
ladri Ma cosa ladri e uno di loro ha
fatto una puzzetta così lunga che si è
fatto la Che
c
Ma che razza di cartoni schifosi stavate
guardando Sì che ci sono Li abbiamo
visti con i nostri occhi e sentiti con
il nostro naso
Wow Che schifo Dai vinto Devi crederci
Ah Lasciatemi stare Non ci credo
son non ci credo ti abbiamo schiacciati
via Devi crederci ci sono ma possono
anche ritornare Sono dei ladri Devi
crederci ci son Immagino che tocchi a me
andare a
controllare Anita guarda in Quest aereo
c'è il WiFi sì e quindi e possiamo
collegarci col cellulare alle
videocamere di sicurezza della casa e
vedere che cosa stanno faccendo i
ragazzi Ottima idea possiamo vederli da
qua dall'aereo dalle videocamere di
sicurezza e vedere se stanno bene Esatto
dai connettiamoci subito collegati
subito presto
ah finalmente Billy è andato in bagno
così posso prendere tutte le altre cose
che ci sono qua insomma c'è un intero
armadio posso allargare il mio
guardaroba le ragazze avevano ragione
sono davvero venuti i ladri proverò a
parlarci e a mandarla
via
[Musica]
Hai visto i miei occhi il mi viso No no
non coprirti Hai degli occhi così belli
No ma poi chiami la Polizia insomma no
no no non chiamo
nessuno Non preoccuparti No guarda
adesso devo proprio scappare Anzi se
vuoi lascio proprio tutta la roba qua
Tanto non mi serve non c'è problema no
aspetta non andartene così presto Almeno
dimmi il tuo nome io Io mi io mi chiamo
io mi
chiamo l'ho fatta Ho fatto la
cacca ma che sta succedendo
qua visto Te l'avevo detto che c'erano
Speriamo che non scorreggi di nuovo
avevate ragione scusatemi ci sono i
ladri ma ho un'idea ho lo scherzo
perfetto per lui
[Musica]
sei tu lo scorreggione Sì ma adesso non
c'è non c'è problema dovevo solo entrare
in
bagno Ragno No in bagno no
ragno
prendi
questo prete la
cam Andiamocene fermo fermi aiuto Vai
vai scappa
scappa ragni Mao ho paura dei ragni non
entrano mai più lì dentro Ma smettila
Adesso pensiamo dobbiamo entrare dentro
la casa di nuovo no no no Sì e ci
dovremmo dividere Ok Ci sei Sì va bene
Tu entri dalla finestra Ok io entrerò in
quell'altra porta là in fondo è perfetto
tranne che io ho paura di stare da solo
non mi interessa ci vai lo
stesso ragazzi venite
qui dobbiamo trovare un nuovo modo per
mandare via i ladri Sì facciamoli tanti
scherzi Questa volta però dobbiamo
spaventarli così tanto che non
torneranno mai più Cioè ma proprio mai
più mai più cioè non c'è neanche una
piccolissima speranza che torni Ma cosa
stai dicendo meglio che non tornino Ma
ti ha dato di volta al cervello va bene
mi è venuto uno scherzo bellissimo per
il ladro cagasotto
[Musica]
ma quello è un
gabinetto Ma è incredibile per me questo
è il
paradiso non volevo proprio
[Musica]
altro eh Un gabinet
Ma che cosa stanno facendo boh Forse
qualcuno se la stava faccendo addosso
fero altrimenti ti mordo tu bel sederino
Ma è un gabinetto parlante ancora non
sei andato via bene ti mordo quel tuo
sederino no le
rettano aspetta aspetta aspetta stavo
pensando una cosa magari possiamo
diventare amici
Sì V diventare amico di un
gabinetto questo lro è proprio
scemo Sì ma non sa devo andare come
facciamo Passami il
joystick Non ci resta che premere questo
pulsante non sta funzionando No Ah
qualcuno devi andare lì
No io non ci vado Mi fa schifo ci vado
[Musica]
io Oh No un
gabineto un gabineto che mi
segue Oh che schifo è pieno di
cacca
che cosa sta succedendo a
casa Credo di aver mangiato troppi dolci
o le
allucinazioni E va bene va bene me ne
vado io volevo solamente che
diventassimo amici mi immaginavo una
bellissima amicizia
[Musica]
insieme
ah ah ah mi ha fatto male giù mi ha
morsicato io me ne
vado Ho fatto scappare il ladro C
ruscita sissima ci sono riuscita Mati
cinque Missione
[Musica]
compiuta Sono entrata nella cucina È
stato facilissimo una una confezione di
patatine ho così tanta ha fame non ho
nemmeno pranzato oggi ma dai non
succederà niente se mangio un po' di
patatine tanto non se ne accorge nessuno
Insomma una pausa non fa mai male no e
Eh
come
Wow questo scherzo è bellissimo Bravi
ragazzi Ah oh oh ma che cosa ci fai qui
Dovresti essere dentro casa Ah sì però
mi stava inseguendo un gabinetto volante
e parlante se per questo io ho trovato
un serpente dentro le patatine un
serpente Sì Ah però non può finire così
non possiamo cadere negli scherzetti e
nelle trappole di questi ragazzini
dobbiamo pensare a un piano per
rientrare Sì giusto siete tutti pronti
stanno per tornare tutti ai posti di
Parè
Sì prontissime
prontissime hanno lasciato la finestra
aperta Che stupidi Vai prima
tu Entra entra
entra questa è la volta buona che
rubiamo tutto e io non sono caduta
perciò vi avevo avvisato di non tornare
mai più Ora peggio per voi
all'attacco Sono bravissimi ragazzi
stanno riuscendo a scacciare i ladri che
bravi in
questo R
pulzone
anche questo anche
questo
Mir via
Sì Missione compiuta siamo riusciti a
scacciare via ladre anche questa volta
sì speriamo che lei
torni
Eccoci ragazzi
CAP Siete tornati sì Ci siete mancati un
sacco anche voi anche voi questa volta
abbiamo visto dalle videocamere di
sicurezza e abbiamo visto che avete
scacciato i ladri bravissimi sì Siete
stati
bravissimi e vi abbiamo portato anche un
premio
Sì dolci dolci dolci
[Applauso]
Sara
dolci il miglior compleanno di
sempre son buoni me li mangio tutti sono
buonissimi sì che buono Buonissimo il
mio preferito eh buonissimo Grazie Anita
Vitale Grazie
[Musica]
Io voglio questo
adesso